this saturday marks 20 years since the
september 11th terrorist attacks 10
years ago a book was published featuring
the letters that family members wrote to
loved ones who were lost on that
terrible terrible day it is called the
legacy letters we met up with three
young people whose letters to their
fathers were included in that book and
they reflected on the past 20 years and
shared their stories of resilience
olivia you were ten
on you were four lauren you were eight
um on 9 11.
i just want you each briefly to tell us
what you remember about that day and the
days following olivia you start please
um i can walk you step by step through
the 11th
it was one of the first few days in
middle school for me olivia perez's
father anthony perez was working as a
technical specialist on the 103rd floor
of the north tower on september 11th
kids were being pulled left and right to
go home early it's fifth period and i'm
in orchestra
and um
they wound up pulling a kid and come on
miss tell us please tell us and just i
don't know i'm not supposed to but okay
you know the world trade center had been
attacked and it was just an instinctual
i mean the sinking feeling in my stomach
you knew your dad was there yeah and i
knew he was no longer here
lauren what do you remember
i have almost the opposite experience if
she can walk you steps to step through
her day i've got
five minutes
lauren charette's father mark charette
usually worked in his office in new
jersey but on september 11th he was
holding an annual planning meeting on
the 100th floor of the north tower
my mother knew he got into the city that
day she sat me and my the older of my
two brothers down and told us that the
towers have been hit
i know i asked her something i couldn't
tell you what it was
and then i know several days later and
this conversation i don't really
remember very well that she must have
sat us down a couple days later it was
definitely the weekend and told us he
was dead the only memory i have in
between about it is somewhat recessed
when we still weren't sure because i
know somebody was saying something and i
know i got super upset
on you were four
yeah so my account of the at that very
day and the days that follow is
it could be even more vague and hazy
um but i do recall that my father tried
to wave at me yelling my name telling me
to wave through the window of the school
bus
which was something that he never never
really recalled he did otherwise
annualend's father ken nguyen who lived
through the vietnam war worked in the
navy command center at the pentagon i
noticed that my father didn't come home
i honestly thought that he would come
back at some point and it was
a couple weeks later when the funeral
came when i saw my father's casket was
pushed into the cremation chamber that's
when i knew that
he's not going to come back
it took
even a couple more years after that even
to thoroughly understand
that
he's not going to come back and try to
live my life
and develop my identity
without
my father
on lauren and olivia mark the 10th
anniversary of 9 11 by writing legacy
letters to their fathers
dear dad you're the greatest man i could
ever know i'm sure any girl who loves
her father as much as i do would say the
same
but from the short time i got to spend
with you
i know you were the greatest person
alive
now that another 10 years have passed
they look back at those letters
reflected on what they mean to them
today
what did you want to say
in that letter
you know i don't even
it was cathartic i want him to be proud
i want him to know that
though his life was cut short that he is
leaving a lasting impact
on the planet
he was
my everything you know
there is still a part of me
that has this very sick twisted hope
that he's sitting somewhere on a beach
in mexico
drinking a beer
and watching us from afar
that that he
got out safe when in reality he was
working above where the planes crashed
and
was not didn't stand a chance
but in a way
is it some is it comforting on some
level even though you know it's not true
and you've acknowledged that to sort of
fantasize it maybe just maybe is it
comforting to you oh yes
very comforting
gosh olivia that's tough
it's tough
on you said that in your letter that you
were angry that you discovered anger
what you were angry about
so
the anger part was trying to understand
that why my father died such in vain
and
basically why the people that that
committed this heinous act
would create such a tremendous
impact that i will have to endure for
the rest of my life especially my
childhood would it would never be the
same
my favorite photo of us
is the one taken on my third birthday
you let me sit
on your shoulders
and we laughed and looked so happy
i also like
the picture of me
wearing a military uniform
that you bought for me
from one of the stores
inside the pentagon
i am saddened
and sometimes angry
that i was forced to grow up
without
a father
i had learned about terrorism
and the war on terror
it's really painful when i try when i
realize that i'm a
i'm
literally a victim of that situation
yeah
it's it's really tough it it struck you
definition
definition is one thing but the visceral
reaction and basically living it is
another
i know for a lot of people it's just a
word exactly it's just a word or it's
something that you see on tv you a lot
of people will will not understand what
the word terrorism
means until
you're
directly impacted by that
and that's something that
it's even it's even hard to describe
it's
even now even now even now
lauren um what struck me about your
letter it was a series of questions
and i loved your questions because it
was something that we could all relate
to i'm graduating in june will you clap
for me do you think i've made good
friends
i stopped going to church doesn't matter
when you get this will you write back
do you miss me as much as i miss you
will you be at my wedding
do you think i'm picking the right clue
do you still love me
most of all i wanted to ask am i still
your little girl
still your little girl
that question really got to me because i
think every daughter at some point asked
that question of her father
why did you decide to write a series of
questions
i wasn't sure what i wanted to do with
this and so i decided i was just going
gonna free write it i was gonna sit down
i was gonna find a place to start and
being my senior year of high school i'm
like how do i write something well you
start with your question right you start
with the thing you want the answer to
and then you find your evidence but once
i found one question i just kept finding
more questions
your questions really got to me the the
simplicity of your questions really got
to me and the last question just sort of
had me on the floor it really did
because it was such a
it was a haunting question to me because
you can't get the answers to any of the
questions but they're all questions that
we want to know the answers to
so i shuffled it i think a couple of
times but that one was always last it
was always last that was the place to
end it that was the one i wanted the
answer to the most did he used to say to
you you're my little girl he used to say
that you know
he might have i don't remember i do
remember some of the things he used to
say to me what do you remember that he
used to say to you um
i remember mostly that he said i love
you a lot
i'll say i love you how do you all feel
about 9 11 anniversaries it's a time
when the nation
stops and pauses and remembers and
certainly on the big anniversaries 5 10
15 and now 20. is the anniversary
something that you
[Music]
dread does it give you some kind of
comfort that it's that it's remembered
or are you just thinking
it's more than just a day for us
olivia
um
the 11th anniversary was the hardest one
for me when i realized i've lived my
life longer with without my father
than i have with
um
and
you know i've i've made great friends
with other children of 9 11 and we all
agree august is the hardest month of the
year
not september
it's that lead up to
x amount of years ago my dad was still
here with me
the anniversary for me
it's taken me 20 years but i'm finally
at a place where i celebrate my father
and i do things that he would like and i
do things that bring me peace
but anniversaries are hard because
that's when you get all those text
messages i'm thinking of you
you know your father would be proud of
you and
can be a stranger you've never met your
father would be proud of you but hearing
those words
just really i think
rocks you yes you're right august is
hojo than september well even the first
week is the temple it's the run up it's
the media it's the constant like in your
faceness but also for me at this point
like i don't miss him anymore on the
11th then on the 12th and on the 13th
then a random day in april then whenever
so for me the anniversary feels more
like it's about other people than it's
about me or even in some ways him i'm
fascinated to hear from you both that
august is harder than september because
in my mind i'm thinking oh that just
must be september must be terrible but
it makes sense when you say august is
harder because you you guys know it's
coming right on you said you promised in
your letter to your dad
that you would make him proud when you
became a man do you think you've done
that yeah 10 years later
now i'm about to turn 24.
i feel like i did
grad school was about to be done i'm
about to be finishing up in december
and
that degree was an honor from my father
because
he didn't get the chance to complete his
you all talked really about making your
dads proud
olivia i honor my father every day by
doing something stupid to make someone
smile
and that was anthony perez in a nutshell
i go into work every day with that
because at the end of the day my father
went to work
and he never left i'm still questioning
it i still don't have the answer um if
you've made your dad proud you don't
have the answer no no
why not lauren
i don't know every time i ask it of
myself i'm like well what am i doing
with my life now it's like
[Music]
i like your answer i think i definitely
make like people's lives better so i
think he'd be proud of that but
i don't have the answer lauren the fact
that you're still here and you're
carrying on your dad's legacy
is really more than enough
i wrote about closure in my letter
and i sit here and i listen to everyone
and
i don't know what closure is anymore
is it having a
a place for me to go visit where he's
buried
is it
coming to peace with what happened is it
forgiving the individuals who
who caused this is it
carrying on his legacy
i don't know anymore i don't i don't
know what closure is
um i've worked really hard to get to
where i am to overcome
this terrible thing and does that mean
it's closure maybe
does it doesn't mean
i don't have moments of utter weakness
some days it's just impossible to get
out of bed i can imagine
have you forgiven you mentioned
forgiveness have you forgiven
the people behind this
carrying hatred in your heart doesn't
help anyone
it's exhausting
it's not worth it
and they held a lot of hatred for
whatever
their reasons were
and i feel bad for that
and it breaks my heart that we all grew
up without
our parents for that
where do you stand on on forgiveness oh
forgiveness
it's for me
in the case of 9 11 forgiveness is
it's a complicated word yeah
for me forgiveness
would mean
just
just giving just liberate myself the
agony and the angst
of that the ford that the attacks forced
me to
endure yeah and understand and process
it
and even just
never mind try to articulate it to other
people yeah it's difficult like how do
you convey something like that yeah um
so it's always going to make me wonder
like what was the motivation
the hat that possibly that caused those
people to have that kind of hate how
does the hatred become that intense i
wonder that too
where does forgiveness sit with you
lauren so
there's for me there's two poets one
like you said anger is exhausting
i it didn't take me very long to forgive
them
like i couldn't be that angry
um also there's that quote if you can be
anything be kind i'd like to think that
i can be kind i like to think that
that's the most important thing is to be
kind to each other
dan
you are my hero
you are always
in my heart
i am so proud
to be your son
i promise to be a good student
and study hard
so that when i become a man
i will make you
up in heaven
happy
and proud of me
love
your son
[Music]
out of the darkness comes light and the
kids of 911 my friends who i now call
family will light the darkness and make
the nation shine
but if i could ask for anything it'd be
one measly little meal with you at a
diner just to talk about life
what heaven's like
and how you and all my friends parents
are getting along most of all
i'd like to hug you one last time
i love and miss you dearly olivia
have you read what i wrote
would you go hiking with me
do you still love me
most of all i wanted to ask am i still
your little girl
forever